a minute on bp then make sure you check
me out on big bro bootleg kid poor kid
gang
it's the bootleg kev show special guest
in here
my guy lieutenant alabama's finest oh
taylor
well i want to congratulate you for
beating your charge i'm a mama congrats
on that
mama
the last time you were here um
i was like it was still in the air like
what was going on you couldn't really
talk about it too much but now it's uh
now that you're on the other side of it
yeah
i know how stressful that is like
waiting to see what happens with a
charger that should be [ __ ] up bro
that should be [ __ ] up for real for
real but you know i got a good faith i
got good faith though shout out to your
lawyer too yeah i had a good day shout
out to you yeah
it really would have worked man i
thought it was old man
yeah it sounded like it was over with
because i just saw you and then that
[ __ ] happened and i was like god damn it
sounds like what is happening
and then you had gotten shot at like you
know the year before
i'm like dude can someone get put this
guy in the house and just just
not let him out i be chilling though
people
um
talk about this new album man is it a
mixtape is it album what is it it's a
project whatever that means
body of work yes
many kids who was misguided growing up
watching the wrong things and [ __ ] you
know
paying attention to the wrong people and
they were they mistakenly showing me
this [ __ ] they ain't even doing it on
perfect they
i'm just not learning this [ __ ]
like positive [ __ ] that i can do
different and [ __ ] no i'm saying so i
want to i want to be the one that
changed
the upcoming [ __ ] i'm trying to
say
um what point in time did you feel like
you were finally starting to kind of
grasp like
the life [ __ ] because it's hard to
really like you know i'm just not i'm
just
probably like
like the last year and a half obviously
you go through traumatic [ __ ] you almost
lose your life and then you almost lose
your life to a charge exactly yeah so
they like the leg the legs like you in
the hell did i just sit down on the
ankle on the [ __ ]
it really was like an eye opening [ __ ]
about life for me you know
yeah do you feel like uh are you moving
different
yeah yeah that's a kid and [ __ ] you know
yeah that's new yeah he doesn't know
yeah that's a kid
security's important man yeah that's a
very important forever it's a very imp i
feel like if you're a certain stature in
the game like
it's almost necessary man
it's not like no [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah that's
it i'm moving around with no security
like you're an idiot
you're a [ __ ] idiot because you mean
a lot to a lot of people exactly and hey
if you gone it's [ __ ] everything's gone
for real then what happens so we were
talking a little bit uh
obviously we saw
kevin lyles went to bat for ysl
uh you're obviously under 300 and you
said that you really would love the way
that they had your back during the whole
process you know a lot kevin love's real
[ __ ] know ain't got the whole 300 for
real for real like they they baked the
[ __ ] the whole time supporting the
[ __ ] family like even when the [ __ ]
first like that one of my first thoughts
like damn bro
very high profile video shoot too it
wasn't like this
you know
like even if i ain't do [ __ ] like y'all
know it look bad you know
so i'm like man that ain't gonna [ __ ]
with me bro but hey they stood on that
[ __ ] though like yeah [ __ ] that that's
amazing you know what it is too it's
like you we always hear it guilty and
too proven innocent but the problem is
is that the public don't think that way
yeah man the public sees a a headline
and they already got their mind made up
so now it's on you
and then they'll sw then they'll make
their own store with the headline like
[ __ ] dude what happened like no i'm
saying [ __ ] coming to me and
asked me like oh so this is this is what
really happened to [ __ ] like i'm like no
i don't know what the [ __ ] yeah
hey we gotta stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our partners our
family at odd socks go to
oddsoxofficial.com
right now
and the promo code bootleg kev it'll get
you 20 off the fly of socks in the world
[ __ ] spongebob
[ __ ] cheez-its
a little bit of pepsi
uh how about how about some underwear do
we like underwear e.t boxers let's go
ahead and just open up a pair of these
boys
so you can see how fly the draws are
ladies and gentlemen because they are
fly by the way they just gave me my own
pair of odd socks go on my social media
and you could see them uh i don't know
if they're gonna be for sale
because let's be honest
who wants to wear socks with my [ __ ]
ugly face on him besides my wife and she
don't even want to wear them there we go
they got the draws they got it all man
get the odd socks basics which i love
just the basic boys these are amazing
comfy socks on socksofficial.com use the
promo code bootleg kev save 20 off let's
get back to the interview you have no
beef with no rappers i'll be trolling
yeah what happened with the no cap thing
huh talk about it this was like was this
last night or the night before they were
like
you're hanging out with pawn you're
hanging out with a.d i'm sure the
flickers flowing yeah with trump
yeah yeah i'll be getting drunk a lot i
like getting drunk damn [ __ ] with no
i'm saying the [ __ ] and [ __ ] i will
sit on me you know i like drinking that
[ __ ]
but with the look with that little
situation i do
[ __ ] up situation that's a [ __ ] up
situation man i don't want to explain do
you regret
uh do you regret like i don't regret
[ __ ] i said i don't know regretting
unless i see it i see it he feel my own
great
like i hate that i did it like that
though
look
that makes sense
you're in the moment you're not even
like understanding that like not even in
a moment like
that [ __ ] was on my chest i wanted to
get that [ __ ] out it was like just
yeah
because people don't even understand
what's going on for it so they build and
they own look
you know
i mean you throw something like that out
there people are going to come up their
own yeah i would troll them don't know
playing with that [ __ ] who playing man
that was a big ad joke fair enough
i mean do you feel like because
obviously you're from a place like
alabama uh
a lot of different cities but the
culture in alabama in terms of just like
hip-hop is like really starting to
finally take off um
lots of superstars at alabama shout out
to uh the homie young blue yeah yeah man
um
but uh
it is is it is it
easier to be for somebody from your own
city it feels like that's always the
[ __ ] like you always have the biggest
issues with people who are from where
you're from is that you think that's the
case because then you get shot like
yeah i got shot oh flute [ __ ] though it
was [ __ ] fighting at the club
you just were in the wrong place at the
wrong time wrong play wrong good bro
right wrong play wrong time but as far
as like the question
i don't think i just feel like it'd be
[ __ ] that'd be going on like everything
like
the naked i ain't gonna see everything
that's going on especially on instagram
that's fair there'll be a lot of [ __ ]
going on people don't be knowing about
you know my feelings beginning
his music is fire your music is fire it
would be crazy
together we did we got a song we got old
song kyle demons hmm so at a certain
point in time things were okay
yeah because i had came back to sit on
some
fam you know i was in california so when
i came back to mobile i want something
someone telling in my seat i'm trying to
get down you know that's fair yeah i
already had a little blood and [ __ ]
i'm trying to work with everybody but
once i started paying attention
and seeing what's going on and [ __ ]
[ __ ] went right that's fair um who was
on this project uh in a league chat with
you here beau
[ __ ] moray
morey's incredible and my name who else
did you say
an elite table yeah you know but you
said did you say something afterwards
you just said moraine that was it yeah
okay
shout out to murray
ain't gonna lie more than my [ __ ] ain't
got a good personality fun to be around
i like oh he's the best yeah i like
people like that he's just a clippers
fan we're just random for someone from
north carolina he's a fan of the
clippers i don't understand it but did
emily choppa try to give you any of his
potions and lotions
no he i'm not oh no
no
i don't know i don't want no postings
and lotions well he'd be curing [ __ ]
here man
yeah he do be kidding [ __ ] this is a
magician
i mean that oh i don't you know the
natural products i believe in the
natural products
no you don't see my i don't do nothing
healthy for real for real i need to
start that's a wild thing to say out
loud i know i'm gonna be doing nothing
wrong he said i'm gonna be doing nothing
healthy
probably the healthiest thing i'll be
doing is performing do you eat do you
drink water i drink a little bit of
water just a little bit i drink a little
water in there
every now and then you drink water so
what's your main beverage are you
drinking soda like okay i drink a lot of
juices and [ __ ] lots of sugar yeah drink
a lot of juices
what's the go-to juice lemonade
i like lemonade simply
simply raw get the raspberry
you know something about life you know a
lot about life big brother yeah i had to
cut that [ __ ] out i was getting too fat
how old are you i'm 25. oh yeah that's
good you're going to get fat soon don't
worry if there's something yeah i don't
think i'm gonna get fat before i go no
no no listen bro you're 25 yeah
you're gonna get fat get fat you got
about two more years left
a hundred percent it's coming
what i don't think i could do it oh i
know you can because you don't you all
you do is drink [ __ ] simply lemonade
[Laughter]
you're about to you're about to have a
lean gut minus the lean real soon y'all
for sure can't get no lean good i had
the six packs out five years old got no
more you'll see you hit that 30. it's
all downhill but you think so oh i know
so i'm gonna start working that do
something
drink water you should drink a gallon of
water a day water
i try man i drink like i drink like half
of one of them a day
that's not what is this
you gotta drink more than that what's
this
this is a a quart
of corn i drink like a half a quart a
day yeah i'll be high
i'll be feeling good i'll be having
energy in anything
yeah i'll be chilling you drink a lot of
soda
nah i drink soda at night which i like
sprite though as i said this what's your
greatest soda of all time is a sprite
it's bright yeah it's bright sprite is a
you know pretty refreshing
mcdonald's sprite is better
yeah yeah light ice the mcdonald's
whatever whatever [ __ ]
deal with the devil they got with
coca-cola
that mcdonald's soda is different that
coca-cola it's got his own taste oh mom
i think they making this [ __ ] in the
back nah they got some sort of [ __ ]
deal with coca-cola they have to does
coca-cola own mcdonald's i don't know i
feel like they're in cahoots somehow
because they got their own flavors they
might be
have you ever had baja blast mountain
dew bob from taco bell
i don't think so it's a pretty good
beginning taco i ain't gonna lie i get
them doritos taco i love them
[ __ ] oh yeah
yeah dorito chocolate in the sierra miss
no you gotta get the baja blast next
time baja bling yeah while you're doing
it make sure you got some cargo shorts
on have some eminem in the walkman
a fox racing t-shirt you know what i
mean
that's gonna give me the whole
experience yep you gotta get the
mountain dew you gotta be playing some
eminem or insane clown posse
have you ever listened to insane clown
posse
nah who that is
don't worry about it you're saying clown
pies yeah who's this is a rap group from
the 90s
from the detroit area and they wore face
paint oh like like juggalos yeah their
fans are druggables so juggalos are fans
of the insane compost man we was in
middle school brother juggalos used to
hate
[Music]
they probably were smoking meth and i
think so i think so they just be chasing
those [ __ ] those knives and [ __ ] the
juggalos was chasing y'all yeah until we
started playing with that iron and [ __ ]
then they had it back up they would just
be chasing it with with knives and [ __ ]
they probably had b.o
they probably had bad odor they probably
had bad they probably like most juggalos
that i know
they're not the most they're not that
they don't shower often that's what i'm
trying to say i'm going on with them
but they love baja blast
as much mountain dew they can get their
hands up so i got drilled like a juggalo
and get it
it's just so you can feel it feel the
whole experience
dad you had beef with the juggalos no
mama they was on that gangster [ __ ] too
my mom they was not no hoes they was
ready to fight all that [ __ ] yeah but
when [ __ ] started playing with that and
though they got their eyes and lead them
along
you said this was in sacramento yeah
there was a sick so did you go to high
school in sacramento yeah i wouldn't
high school segment you know and i went
to high school in atlanta before i went
to middle school and i love them too so
how was uh how was the high school years
in sac it was cool i loved even the
teachers the teachers ain't even called
me by my real name they call me p's it's
always been the thing where's the name
come from obviously the pc the pc part
i don't know
somebody told me p's i mean plea in
california or like like like keeping it
p's oh you're ringing
shout out to the bay for really coining
push and pee excellent people be acting
like there's some new [ __ ] yeah they
should've been around [ __ ] that should
have been around me because i've heard
larry june talk about that [ __ ] for a
very long time
don't not pushing pp
you say pushing pp
boss pause
pushing p pushing pee pee
oh mama
oh no
no
no
i'm pushing pp i don't know what
everybody else pushing me i'll put it
pee pee though
straight up
you know
light though
push it peepee lose it peak peak
go to bluetooth.com and use the promo
code bootleg and you'll save 20 off if
you go to bluechu right now did you know
that bluechew has the same active
ingredient as cialis and viagra but it
gets delivered right here oh that would
you just talk about bluetooth yeah
what'd it do it makes your dick [ __ ]
broccoli gets it down imagine you go on
a first date with a chick right but when
i get older
listen don't worry about that what we're
worried about is you're trying to
impress a [ __ ] you're trying to just
break that that thing in half round one
round one fight
maybe you're going through some stress
maybe you're like you know i could use a
little more pep in my step get some blue
chew right to your door no doctor's
appointments it's all online
bluetooth.com keyword bootleg twenty
percent off see how we just work that in
so we don't have to do that
cause we can we can't let this is just
like bluetooth you get a whole month
free i just said twenty percent off it's
not even got no end got no like things
well i you owe this [ __ ] right now but
when i get older i'm gonna need this
[ __ ] type [ __ ] no
no i love it it's great uh yeah and you
get a whole month you get your first
month free with my promo code bootleg at
bluetooth.com i [ __ ] up i may be
confusing my sponsorships anyway so
uh
what are you listening to right now oh
it's not your [ __ ]
louis capaldi
okay excellent studio
uh little [ __ ] name gmk
uh
kevin gates new album i like that i'm
kevin gage trump
i like that [ __ ] a lot
i like his freestyle the uh
the super grandma freestyle i like that
one too
i mean he said
what everybody feels yeah yeah
and he said it in a respectful way i
feel like
he did he was like jay-z man my bad you
know my bad but i'd drink your wife's
piss but
oh yeah that ain't [ __ ] up man
yeah damn that's [ __ ] up imagine if
like you came in and your wife was here
you're not married
and i was like oh hey hey peasy my bad
i would drink your pee that that's a
wild oh [ __ ] yeah
with that being said it's kevin gates
whatever [ __ ] told me like
if a [ __ ] told me like a lot p's
that hoes so fine like well i got them
i'll be like yeah man my whole raw no
yeah
nah i mean i got good taste yeah yeah
kevin gates you don't try to step no man
you and gates going on tour together is
going to be crazy yeah you know
he's a he's a great performer
yeah
i plan on learning a lot of [ __ ] from
bro yeah his live shows are very amazing
like he's great and i think that you
guys are doing some pretty big venues
like amphitheaters and [ __ ] it's gonna
be great
yeah so you guys got a good relationship
yeah bro cool yeah cool he's i feel like
uh
he's like
a very inspirational guy if you really
get to know him for sure yeah i've been
watching bro like for the longest you
know what i'm saying i'm following about
music
listening
and [ __ ] i feel like i got a good
understanding of the type of person bray
is that's why i [ __ ] when the way i do
type [ __ ] he's definitely uh
you know
yeah he's a connoisseur of the of of the
womanly uh of the woman
of the woman
he's pushing pp for sure yeah
so mama that what i'm saying i'm pushing
pp
you know
hey that one on my own i'm pushing pv
jesus christ that's my new [ __ ] man we
pushing pp man area
i'm pushing pp hey man i know you're in
a good place chargers are behind you new
projects coming out mm-hmm are you going
to be uh i mean like we got what how
many months we got left we got like six
months left no five months left in the
year is this the last project of the
year you're gonna try to keep maybe put
something else out i'm gonna try
yeah i'm gonna try
is there uh is there any uh
you know lately there's been a lot of
people doing collab albums
collab mix tapes oh yeah i'll do that
i don't know who though i was gonna say
who would you do a project with
certainly not no cap but someone else
i don't know
hmm
i don't know
who would be fire
ken who will be [ __ ] who should peasy do
a whole project with
give us your thoughts vallejo ken
don't [ __ ] keep it to yourself
hendrix
you and kevin gates should be fired oh
you're here yeah
bro
you and kevin gates would be nice
i wouldn't mind you and mozzie i think
that'd be fire oh yeah that'd be dope
that'd be dope hey free my dog too man
man yeah he's hey hey i don't know his
team shot enough content though because
i swear since he got his he turned
himself in his ig boom hey you know you
know who else who else doing that good
too oh hot boy free hot butt free hop
away yeah he been dropping the video
probably like a week i've been loving it
and [ __ ] like
shout out to hot boy
nice guy
yeah
do you feel like uh
with like everything happening with you
know obviously you got label mates uh
ysl that are facing the ricoh [ __ ] does
that make you uh reconsider likes
saying certain fictional things on
records
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
but then again i'll be thinking about
that [ __ ] like so what if i got them get
on the movie and then they give me a
script and i say like something well
that's how i was gonna say i think i
think since you know your [ __ ] is
fictional i think you should start every
project off dirk just did this he
started everything i see on his props
little mama's yup it's all fake so now
you got to start your projects out there
i feel like low-key i know jay-z's
trying to push the uh
there's like a law he's trying to push
uh that he's lobbying that would make it
like
he off-limits to use uh artist lyrics
against him in court
so hopefully that happens but if not you
low-key might have to drop the little
disclaimer yeah yeah no why not but i'm
saying though like
why didn't why all right johnny depp
what movie that was he played in he was
killing everybody [ __ ] there's a i mean
pirates of the caribbean who's killing
people yeah so why did i investigate his
personal life oh
keanu reeves why aren't they on keanu
reeve's head john wick killed a lot of
people i ain't putting the police on no
[ __ ] no [ __ ] like that what i'm just
saying we need that same speak man you
know i think you just put the police on
johnny depp you know what i'm saying
he's like no i'm just saying like we
need that same respect have you ever
been in a crazy johnny depp amber heard
type
christian rock slash blue face type
toxic relationship wait who what have
you ever been in a [ __ ] okay
oh with a crazy vision johnny depp had a
[ __ ] [ __ ] in his bed [ __ ]
chrishon rock who's a blue faces lady
shhh she's by all guys
i think she's a psychopath
actually
i'm pretty sure she's a psychopath yeah
i think she throw it out yeah she
thought i was she broke into his house i
liked him type of whole thing she cut
herself open and wrote him a love letter
on the wall in her blood and then stole
his g-wagon and drove it across the
country they got arrested so wait hold
on
she broke in the house
allegedly broke in the house no no not
allegedly cut herself open
she wrote a note on the wall in her in
her blood then she took the g wagon
drove it across the country and got
arrested in like somewhere random state
i would have married that [ __ ]
jesus that's love
man hold on she broke in the house cut
herself open and wrote a letter on that
day i won i was like i want everybody
out real you know you just you just
shook a charge you know what i mean
you just cut yourself over and wrote a
letter with your blood on my wall you
don't find that disturbing yeah i'm not
that's it cute
that's it that's cute though don't keep
it
that's cute i like this [ __ ] if i make
you feel like that we meant to be on my
mom
you don't feel like that no man this
gotta be crazy about me
what if it's someone who you're not
crazy about
what if it's like a fan like what if
it's like what if it's like a fan and
the fan's like you know 58 got diabetes
i mean got monkey pucks
but they [ __ ] love you they're like
obsessed with you they think that they
know you because of their music you come
home back back to wherever you live in
my [ __ ] oh and they're in there and
they're just [ __ ] they're wearing
their clothes blood notes all over the
[ __ ] place
they [ __ ] they [ __ ] sacrifice the
goat in your little in your living room
just to try to get you to [ __ ] like
random [ __ ] that i don't random
[ __ ] yeah i don't know like i
got a soft spot for my fans [ __ ] so i'm
gonna say a random [ __ ] no
[Music]
i'm just saying i'm just asking about
putting you in the situation
hypothetical
so i walked so i getting this all my
aunts and my moms are baby duds so i
like yourself my mom my mom's a bb-w
if i get in the house it's a big [ __ ]
in the middle of the flow she's a big 58
year old [ __ ] with diabetes 58 58.
she's a old [ __ ] but she loves you bro
she wants to make you a [ __ ] her
[ __ ] kid low-key she's like i want
you like let momma take care of you
i'm with it
[ __ ] yeah oh she got monkey pox though
yeah i ain't on it
oh god
i can't [ __ ] with the monkey pop get
[ __ ] with the boogie box
look the project go run it up uh no
guidance misguided
[ __ ] no guidance is a chris chris brown
record
uh go stream go see you on tour you're
gonna be on tour with the kevin gates
um
anything else going on you wanna shout
out
pushing pp
pushing peepee
there we have it